near the city of bordeaux have already
torn through nearly 20 000 hectares of
land found by strong winds now more than
30 000 people have been evacuated since
the fire started a week ago natasha
butler visited a shelter for homeless
people in paris is providing a respite
from the intense heat
tightly squeezed into one rucksack are
all of olivia's possessions he's been
homeless in paris for several years he
usually sleeps on the street but with
temperatures soaring in the city he's
now spending his nights in a metro
station where it's cooler during the day
he comes to this shelter for some
respite
what i do during this hit wave is i
always keep a bottle of water with me
and some fruit juice and i make sure
that i eat i find food no matter where
and then i spend time here
dozens of homeless people use the
shelter to escape the sweltering heat
outside it's also a place to rest or
socialize
a center like this is a lifeline at any
time of year but particularly during the
heatwave people can have a shower they
can charge their telephones and they can
wash their clothes
the charity that runs the shelter says
there are more than 2
500 people sleeping on the streets in
paris and for them the summer heat can
be as dangerous as the cold in winter
dehydration headaches some people can't
cope with heat so they need to be
careful stay in the shade to keep cool
and try not to stay alone
after record temperatures in several
regions of france this week
meteorologists predict cooler weather in
the coming days that might make life a
little easier for those sleeping rough
although it certainly won't make them
any less vulnerable natasha butler al
jazeera paris